that is the deepest thing i have ever
heard
in my entire life wow you see it now wow
in my entire life
plot twist plot that was interesting yes
[Music]
oh so episode 44 cause four four
get your [ __ ] merch that we're
wearing today
you got a nice what's that tangerine
nice tangerine
nice mandarin color i've got the
silhouette it was the
the gunmetal grey
so yeah man [ __ ] secure your things
cuz
um metal grey such an idiot uh
obviously spotify apple podcast
listeners click subscribe
we're slowly becoming the biggest
podcast on planet earth slowly but
surely you man
slowly becoming the biggest podcast on
planet earth i think we're about third
i'm pretty sure we're third give or take
i'm pretty sure we're third or fourth
so yeah keep the train rolling ronin
keep the train rolling and uh yeah man
do you think um that's funny obviously
mission 1k
so guys we're moving hot and fast with
the mission 1k
uh we've got like i think this week
alone we've got like four new pay three
or four new patreons which is
always a pleasure so guys thank you so
much um
and yeah if you don't know a mission 1k
get us to 1 000
pounds a month on patreon and foodhead
and i will start dropping
two episodes of shits and gigs a week
and um yeah man we're gonna play hard oh
just an update as well
for all our patreon listeners or soon to
become um
new patreon episodes will now be coming
every first of the month every first of
the month you're gonna get a new patreon
episode
i usually do it kind of third or fourth
weekend and it's it's all i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] with uploading it on time
and it's all over the place and people
never know when to expect the new
episode they just know it comes once a
month
but first of the month every month
that's when it's going to come three
pound a month
sign up [ __ ] do it now mission 1k
let's go that's 10 p a day i want my
money
dead for your day run me my pee run me
my pee that's 10 p a day yeah
you got that you get this one for free
get the cheeky cheeky a day
support us man you got that all right
cool so
um fan request unless you've got urgent
business no
nothing i've got [ __ ] to talk about
there's not nothing else so yeah fan
requests so
i'm actually going to shout out lady i'm
sorry so lady sent us this fan request
uh topic [ __ ] ages ago and i was like
yeah we'll do it
and i completely forgot before you even
get into that can i i'll shout out laney
again like you're so dope
like you've been riding with us from
jump
not from jump from like early though
from earlier not from jump from early
couples people from jump
a couple of people are from jump kill
people from jump from jump jump
but laney you're a true one man we we
[ __ ] with you thank you for that
yeah lenny's cool man you're off ends
you're overseas and it's so
yeah that makes it better yeah i will
not feel bad i want to do a shout out
thing
um we'll do a proper once yeah we'll do
a proper one man because
yeah ladies who else is top um i don't
know all their names that's the thing
like because obviously i see a lot of
them on youtube
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah instagram
australian georgie she's joke
which one's georgie oh yeah yeah yeah
painting georgie
she followed us from tom she's from
jumps she's from jump
jump jump she's from jump yeah yeah yeah
that's when we had like less than 100
followers bruv
jump and um oh what's his name mark mark
donny mark
who won the competition yeah yeah
yeah he's he's
he's gang stop it he's right fam every
time we upload an episode by myself
first in the comments
man's always there like let's go
so anyway yeah i'll do some more shout
outs anyway now um but
uh laney laney laney where was your take
let me find it
um [ __ ] i should have just pulled up
in it
laney laney laney laney laney laney
laney
uh what was the what was the main topic
what was she talking i have no idea
okay cool so let me read it
scenario okay cool so you just hooked up
with a girl
the night before that you have been
texting for a couple of weeks
you wake up and she's sitting on top of
you at first you're turned on but you go
to rob sleep out of your eye and you
feel something in your hand
it's handcuffs and she's coughed herself
to you
in confusion you look up at her and she
puts the key in her mouth and swallows
it
what do you do
so you wake up you hang up to her this
yeah and she's just swallowed the key
we're handcuffed together in bed we're
handcuffed together in bed
and she swallowed the key
is is it my guy or is it a yeah it's a
yeah you've been talking to a couple
weeks
i think it's the first time you [ __ ]
so you've been
talking stage yeah yeah [ __ ] the night
before yeah
nutted and kipped yeah you wake up and
you're like
and you've got to wipe your eye and just
jingling and her hand comes with it
there's a bit of a straight yeah yeah
yeah hey what the [ __ ] is this brother
and she's sitting on top of you
and you're together and you're like ah
what's up
and then she just puts the key on her
tongue and just first of all any yeah
that can swallow a key
nonchalant she can swallow what she
wants
any yak that can just swallow a key any
act like a swallowed metal
bro she's a trooper she is a [ __ ]
trooper she's a rider she is a ride or
dier
that will turn me on that would hurt
i would be so petrified but so turned on
at the same time
we would probably in my haze we would
probably just
[ __ ] then and there yep and then after
dealing with it after
what the [ __ ] is going on vomit that key
now
fam gag it up gag it up or i'll gag it
for you
fam because i'm not staying attached to
you but
the initial take i would it would turn
me the [ __ ] off [ __ ] on
this is what i think it is it would turn
me the [ __ ] on because i would drapes it
to the fence afterwards
but it would turn me the [ __ ] on i was
thinking this is how you know man
obviously we all say girls are crazy
those are [ __ ] crazy
but guys are crazy in this is how i know
we're just as crazy as women
because i'll put a scenario to you i
already know what your response is going
to be
okay and i can't remember i might have
written it down actually because i can't
remember word for word but i had in my
head all right
hit me hang on
okay cool cool so pre this so
so let's say you you link a bath ting
buff
banging tits arse stomach legs
nipple piercings the whole thing i love
a nipple piercing
she's banging so you bang her yeah
all good you keep saying the same
scenario yeah you kip
you wake up and there's as you wake up
there's wax strips
all over you all over your body wax
strips galore
on your beard on your balls on your
[ __ ]
wax strips and you're tied to the bed
and she's just smiling cars and one by
one
she thinks it's sexy in her head but
she's [ __ ] tapped
and she just yanks the rap [ __ ] off
clump of your beard is gone
your balls are strained your gooch
everything wax
wax wax wax like she's just torturing
man and you're livid
obviously you're livid so after it's
done obviously after it's done you're
just like
you're gone because you threatened a
smacker
and you just dip everything done you
block our number everything yeah yeah
so three months later obviously that's
the worst experience ever
yeah three months later you get a dm
requesting that little one request
open it up it's a picture of her yeah
bent over butt plug in
saying what are you gonna do
obviously i'm going obviously i'm going
over
obviously i'm going over i think
obviously you are obviously you're
not even growing back yet i'm going
to work with a patch from your business
explanation
but that one picture you're going
straight back straight there
that's how men are tapped cause i'm
gonna show back as well straight over
all men are
picture of butt plug in butt plug
already in just sitting in there
bent over she's bent over now she's like
calm
no i'm coming
obviously rags of course that's a
no-brainer
of course it's a no-brainer i'm going as
well i'm going straight over there
my dick will be solid so hard
i'll go straight over and i i will no
i'm crazy because she's probably gonna
do it again
on your way there you just got to think
of the game plan like i can't let this
[ __ ] tie me up fam i can't fall asleep
can't fall asleep
as soon as i'm not i'm gone as soon as
she tries to grab my hand nah
get off me let me take control bro let
me nut and let me dip
she can't wax the other side of my beard
off she couldn't because at this point
i've already got a goatee because i've
obviously
yeah yeah yeah obviously you've yeah
yeah yeah cleaned off this and i've just
got a go-to
vex already and vex that she has to see
the byproduct of what she's done to me
do you know what i mean
your effects that you know that she won
that round you know
she won that round because there's
nothing you could like
you couldn't just go and be like [ __ ]
her and then
it goes back you actually had to make
amendments to your life and when you've
come back to her to [ __ ] her again
she can see that what she did to you has
actually affected you
you've had to change your look and
you're still coming back to [ __ ] her
that's crazy that is crazy you
understand how crazy that is i know but
it just goes to show you how much
a picture can just do anything for you
anything on like we've talked about this
before unwarranted
sexy pics are the sexiest thing if i
have to ask for it
i might as well not have it yeah that's
the thing as well like i don't like
asking for it
but sometimes i like asking for it
sometimes i like if i ask for it and i
get it
then i'm like gang with no explanation
you just get like probably like an hour
send me something nice and they actually
sent you something they sent you
something within the day and you're like
oh
i wasn't expecting it but thank you for
that bro yeah yeah
but yeah just the just the something
just to wake you up in the morning
you're looking you're just like ah and
sometimes
when you get like a snap or whatever you
see it's purple you know it's
probably slight images or
instagram when you see that bluetooth
play you see
your dms and there's that blue play and
you're just like
you have to make sure you're in the
right place at the right time to breathe
so you bring it
comfortably because you never know where
it could be does that mean
you need to make sure and this is the
thing you don't know how long it's going
to be so you need to make sure you can
watch it then and there you can assess
it properly assess it properly so i'm
not opening it until i'm
free because it can't just be a quick
like look like that because that little
that little bomb's like ticking down
from it's gonna go
that's gonna go as soon as i see that
blue circle
i'm just oh god it could be a good day
unwarranted
nude slash video slash anything sexy is
oh so the man's the life fam do you know
the [ __ ] jarring
thing is is it slowly going down um
when you're when you think you're gonna
get a nude when you see
like when you say that either the purple
square snap or the blue circle
and you think oh
you think [ __ ] nude and you open it and
she's just like
she's doing something dumb she's doing
something dumb yep
are you just like what was the point fam
how many other people did you waste time
how many other
people's time did you weigh sorry do you
know what i mean because it's not she
didn't just send that to me
nah how many other people's time did you
watch [ __ ] like that annoys
me [ __ ] like that annoys me but it's a
gamble because you never know you never
know
you have to open it same time who am i
to expect a nude do you know what i mean
like
yeah why shouldn't i appreciate a little
cutesy yeah
see little pick that's so true we're
such [ __ ]
we're such awesome we are we literally
are oh we are the actual arseholes
[ __ ] that's hilarious bro because who
are we to expect it
who are we who the [ __ ] am i to just
assume if i'm getting
picks and vids through there's a nudity
maybe she just wants to know how my
day's going
do you know what i mean maybe she just
wants to know how i'm doing but i'm like
oh
blue click and she's just like ah
oh she's drinking a new smoothie yeah
that's
[Laughter]
if i open up a thing it's like hi oh my
days i'll be so confused i'll be so
confused
fam oh brav and then i'm just like
wasted my time yeah you [ __ ] but it's
like who am i to even
who am i to ask or expect for respect
that's the thing because
yeah yeah yeah yeah i would expect such
ego the
ego to just expect titties
jeremy the eager to just expect tea
that's how much it just brightens up my
day
oh yeah or how much it would brighten up
any man's oh yeah i mean
oh yeah and that's the thing i would say
vice versa but it's not vice versa
because a guy can't just send a girl sir
and that's sexy
because he's talking about this before
like the the dick pics it's
hard to send a girl something like a
picture-wise
and for them to be like oh because in my
opinion it is but maybe in theirs it's
just
yeah it's not because i was just about
to say some yats just think guys are hot
so if they send a face pick to them
that's their world
family and i'm like i'm not gonna stand
there and take a picture of my face and
send it to you i'm not
i i can't stand there and send a picture
nothing unless sometimes it's stupid
like goofy or something then i'll send
it i'm a [ __ ] goofball
that's my problem is that i'm a goofball
and people can't take me seriously
because i can't take myself seriously
so when a yes like send me something i'm
like
how can i make this funny but i know i'm
drying up vaginas when i send her
something funny yeah because i know what
she really wants
yeah she wants manning them calvins she
was
she was a man oiled up in the calvins
and i might send like something in a
banana suit or something bro
i'm just trying to goof it up because i
don't know probably it's just a it's
probably just an insecurity thing deep
down
but just like i know i'm about to dry
this fanny up yeah as soon as i send
something stupid
i'm just i'm drying out sometimes you
just never know on their perspective
never know because imagine this too like
yeah true that's true but yeah like i'm
dead if we're doing a back and forth for
future reference
if anyone ever wants to do a back and
forth newton with me it won't go well it
won't
send me all the crud and i'll type all
the crud back i will type
the most i would type the most to you
but
don't ever expect saturn back in picture
form
you just don't you're just going to have
to go through my highlights or something
yeah
yeah just pick whatever you want to take
whatever you want from me
from my timeline but it's not you're not
going to get what you want in this
you're just not like even facetime cause
it's a
no i don't face time you know i haven't
faced i mean i've been placed i mean
years
i don't face time at all i don't i did
for a time
like i i probably did like
probably about five six years ago but
now i can't remember last time i faced i
can't remember last time on facetime
do you remember when june locked down
how
how much house party was such a thing
it's so oh it is going down [ __ ]
it's so dead now i think i used it once
i used it once i used it once and that
was it
were you you weren't in it at that time
we used it at the time i think was it
whose birthday was it someone's birth
oh i don't think so i think we just
wanted to go on it
it worked but i was i remember
specifically i was watching i think my
phone was charging i was watching a
movie
and then obviously my the phone was
ringing on the house party thing and
then it stopped
by the time i saw my phone the it had
stopped ringing mm-hmm i was like
i wasn't going to stop in the movie to
call you man [ __ ] it no that was
literally that was the only time
everyone was in a group chat yeah yeah
we did the house bike team but it was it
was cool like it was a it's such a
novelty
it was such a novelty cuz and it was
just like
i did it once for my boy's birthday
obviously he had his birthday's not
obviously well yeah his birthday during
quarantine
so we did um we did a house party vid
thing it was fun as [ __ ]
to be fair but i was the one and only
time i did it i didn't do it i didn't
eat the
time ago it's it's so annoying how many
times the thing pops up if someone goes
on how's play it says oh oh i locked
that off immediately
i locked that off immediately because
that was pissing me off
all day every day every day all day
everything it was [ __ ] yeah house party
was
rinsed as soon as it came it went
straight and the
the voice notes on twitter
voice notes on twitter i think that's
like like a month ago it was a hype for
like a day and then it died i don't
think anyone does it anymore yeah
i'm not seeing it you gotta have
something original for like longevity
if you want something like it has to be
original there were a couple original
things on there like
when when it first dropped the voice
notes on twitter
there were guys doing like old school
answering machine things so they played
like an old school arm beating in the
background
like 112 or slightly smooth
uh yeah i know i'm not at the phone
right now but call me back on this this
this this
and the music it was sounds so smooth
so smooth that's jokes that's like
but apart from that it died a quick
death
a quick death so that was pointless it
happens that was very very important be
like that sometimes man
it does newton's like it's hard to yeah
to make it last it's hard to drop a new
ticket it was pointless that was a
that was a pointless thing for twitter
to do in my opinion yeah yeah it's like
what does it actually achieve
why would you want voice nets on twitter
it's not the format for it
yeah it's not exactly exactly exactly
you just there's lanes
there's lanes to this and sometimes
unfortunately you just have to stay in
your life
it don't branch out bro you just have to
because it's clear it didn't work you
didn't bang
bang for a day i'm not going to start
giving political advice to people
i would never give political because i
need to stay in my lane people tell me
to [ __ ] off
i know nothing about it i haven't i
don't have enough information to provide
a
an opinion and it's pointless point it's
a [ __ ] it's [ __ ] pointless bro
soul pointless but yeah gee um you know
what i realize as well
hit me you man actually let me come on
camera with my head chew out over
quarantine
my hair was chewed the [ __ ] out
i had i had rabid waves
just poking cuz little knots just poking
out
i was editing it was like the [ __ ] is
this
mom has just letting me look like a
[ __ ] idiot
that's why you could wear the hats in it
bravo yeah yeah i should have kept some
that's what
that's where i wanted to go with it no
not one person tweeted or commented or
messaged me and said put that back on
put the hat back on please james j.j
put that back on you were doing better
with that my hair was chew out
but it's fun fade is back
man just looked at the camera phone
thumb
fade is back fade is bug fade is back
i was gas to go barbers i bet you were
gaster
barbers when you sexy when you text me
say it
i just got a trim and man sprang me
around the chair like a princess
i was dying fam spun me in the chair
like a princess i felt like a yeah
when the little brush thing was on my
neck it was purring like a kitten
i was having fanny flutters and all
sorts because it felt good
it felt gorgeous the most therapeutic
thing in the world it's amazing
sometimes when i get a trim it's so
therapeutic bro i have kept it before
it's so therapeutic 100 kips before
my hair being rubbed and touched or
whatever it sends me to sleep i love it
i love it i don't know why i've been
booking haircuts every week
same day every every friday me and him
have just been hooking up
it's so live let's get another one this
week at some point this weekend i'm not
gonna stop and jim we're going gym today
oh my first day back today so yeah can't
wait
brav yeah you man jim is we're back on
this gym thing so you're gonna see
james are going to change the game now
in it you my food head was the big one
you i don't know you don't know where
you started you remember during covered
you said when gym's open you're going on
steroids you remember this was about 10
episodes
i did i do remember well you know how i
remember because mandem was
sending me articles bear man were
messaging me like i swear
okay cool so this is what you want to do
that will scare me
that would scare me some of the fans are
invested so yeah i got bear articles is
i reckon my jeans will come through and
i'll just get wham anyway
[Laughter]
so yeah we'll see man uh well i went jim
the other day in my
chest is sore cause i can't wait to to
just be surrounded by metal
i can't wait bro we're gonna chuck it
today we're gonna chuck it today i'm
excited we'll be training anyway
i don't know i'm easy i definitely want
to do cardio
cardio yeah we'll bank cardio definitely
want to hit i need to hit the bike
wait the bike let's hit i want to hit
the assault bike
i don't know if i want to do they're
hard i know that's why i don't know it's
been
four months i don't know whether a
[ __ ] mountain bike thing
is what i want to stop all right all
right all right cool i want to ease
myself
i have a feeling it's going to feel like
it's my first time going to the gym and
you know i'm surprised because obviously
i went the other day i think you'll be
surprised that's what i thought i would
feel
but it's once you're warm it's normal
again you're a little bit weaker
but it's normal again probably going to
be a lot weaker i feel like
my muscles have deflated because i've
got
pigeon chest bro i've got a pigeon i've
got a dad
tummy a dad tummy and a pigeon and no
titty
and my arms are dead string beans i've
got
no hamstring and no cough bro i'm out
here wearing cycle shorts under here
it's just tiny bruh i look like a yoga
instructor
these men don't know what i used to
bring speaking of yoga
there's one thing that i value um i
valued
going back to work it sounds so weird
obviously during quarantine
one of my goals was to stretch a lot
more but because i had no motivation
to train obviously because i was i had
no motivation to do home training yeah
what i wanted to do was go to the gym
yeah
yeah i didn't stretch as much yeah yeah
yeah but now that when work started
three or four weeks ago
i've stretched almost i stretched like
five times a week every night
every night now obviously i use the
roller and the mat yeah yeah yeah
and i bought that two years ago and i've
only just used it frequently this month
it's made so much difference to my
quality of life
because my routine obviously the hours i
work now
they're late a lot later i get the
afternoon to myself like i'm going to
sleep well
but there are times where i come home
and all i want to do is shower and go to
bed yeah
but i don't i don't think i've ever said
this on a podcast but i suffer from
um anterior pelvic tilt so that's it's
just like a chronic back pain
um obviously you know about that mm-hmm
so i've
always wanted to like roll out every
single time but it's just it's just long
sometimes
but now i've got because the weekend i
went back to work it was
just the busiest weekend because every
[ __ ] wanted to go to a restaurant
yeah everyone was excited yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah busy yeah yeah yeah
busy oh [ __ ] i was sweating my feet [ __ ]
that
i'm not sweating at work you can't make
me but as soon as i'm feeling sweat
and humidity and and fluster yeah i'm
gone i'm ripping off my dicky bone i'm
gone
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out i'm out cause
[ __ ] that
no but anyway yeah um i've just got into
the habit of routine of
i'll come home i'd probably like have a
spliff or something
have a shower and then probably put
something on like food that i want to
eat with it for the night yeah
and then just stretch bro and roll out
and stretch for about 30 minutes fifth
thirty
fifteen to three good good bro the way i
sleep that the first time i did it after
the weekend
back i think i did it on sunday night i
slept and i'm
i slept and i woke up in the same
position and i slept for 11 hours
[ __ ] it was like the time in leeds where
we just slept and stayed there my hip
that time oh my god was [ __ ] broken
bro now i do it five i do it five days a
week
minimum or four to five days a week bro
stretch is a game changer
you know what is as well certain things
i've been having the opposite of that
with my morning routine so recently
obviously i know gyms have been coming
i'm thinking i'm a fat mess i don't
actually want to go to the gym
looking like yeah i know what you mean
like i want to
get a head start of this so i can knock
off five percent of the dust
and then go straight into the gym and
actually start doing [ __ ] so i've been
stretching as well
but what i've been doing in the mornings
is this like
getting up before i shower because
usually i just want to get up shower
and then get on my date i've been going
straight into the kitchen because
i've been having like a liter of water
i'll back like a whole liter of water
i'll have two like fresh mangoes
and i'll have like my vitamin d my
vitamin c and my fish oil tablets
every single morning water tablets
mangoes
nice and then when i get in the shower
after that fam afterwards i feel like
i'm ready to tackle
the whole week really i feel amazing
afterwards it's just like a routine
because like i think it's more like a
mental thing where i'm just like
i'm about to be healthy like my day
brightens up when i do it
and i had one day where i didn't do it
and i also had one day where i had like
a croissant for breakfast instead of a
mango
just just just like i had it in the
house and i was like oh i fancy that
you can feel it yeah i felt sluggish and
the more healthy i eat
the more my body's hating eating [ __ ]
yeah like um
i had ice cream the other day 100
lactose intolerant
before i was speculative yeah 100
my stomach caused as soon as i ate it
not even like the next day or a few
hours as soon as
i was burping tasting ice cream when i'm
burped i'm just like i want to be sick
like you have you ever been so disgusted
at yourself and you just hate
everything about you yeah that's how i
felt yeah and that's why i couldn't
sleep the other night as well i was
tossing and turning in bed
tossing and turning and burping and
farting
from i had the tiniest bit of ice cream
the tiniest little pot of ice cream
cause
it was smaller than like a small ben and
jerry's it was smaller than that just a
little
bro i was rolling in bed oh and i was
just like
i can't have ice cream anymore it's
probably for the best but it's just i
can't have ice cream
i can't have cream i can't have dairy
clothes because my body hates it
but i know give me three weeks without
it
my stomach's gonna be flat flat yeah my
body's gonna exude all the toxins yeah
yeah it hates it
it gets inflamed when i have to ice
cream cause it's flamed
my body gets inflamed i i get flamed
with sugar sugar in general like sweets
and stuff
i was trying to give up sweets like the
past month or so so hard
or try and cut down as many sweets as i
eat because sweets are the devil they're
the devil but i love them
they're amazing but they're the [ __ ]
devil you can't have them
your teeth will drop out as well you
know when you get furry teeth when
you've been back in sweets
and give it a rubbing like oh my teeth
are filthy my teeth are [ __ ] filthy i
hate it
but sweets are amazing i prefer them to
chocolate all day
hundred percent one million sometimes i
want chocolate
like a brownie or a waffle or chocolate
bro
that's what i want
it just sits in me so nice but does it
just it makes me feel like [ __ ]
i think that's what i love about sweets
as well is that they don't make you feel
like [ __ ]
when you eat it's just like it's like
chewing gum like it doesn't make you
feel anything
um maybe for you but for me yeah because
i don't i don't eat sweets in moderation
no you don't you eat like a pack of
i eat sweets like if you get those those
good those good ones
the softer chewy whatever like the
foreign every man that lives in england
go to spa
and get the one pound fruit sweets like
they've got like
orange lemon beer strawberry and
raspberry salad it's
it's called like fruit juice or
something it's the best sweets you will
ever eat
they're a pound and they're banging
they're amazing you'll go for
packing them in one sitting in one
sitting especially if i'm baked
oh yeah if i'm baked i'm eating them all
i mean in the morning i'm not sharing
them
so i'll buy two one whole pack for me
and a human can deal with daddy with the
rest
bro they're good we was it remember when
i said
i wanted to not just spit i'm playing
ball no are we good
um we ate them on on here one time fam
on the pod we got bear comments
we've got bear comments i stopped
[ __ ] they thought they were chewing
gum in it you were [ __ ] chewing gum
we were chomping i remember when i was
editing it i text you in and i was like
we're never even
on camera ever because it sounds
disgusting i remember we were chomping
on it but they tasted good
have you ever you know when you watch
netflix
do you ever watch do you have
how can i explain it okay you know when
you're cooking food right
and you eat something for yourself it
tastes banging but when someone else
cooks it for you
it's like this tastes banging do you
know what i mean so in the sense of
watching netflix
there are times during coffee obviously
me and better will just watch anything
on netflix
i've got we share it we share the
netflix so i've got my account
and she's got her profile on my account
so every time i'd watch stuff to get
we'd watch that together and i choose
i'd watch it on my profile yeah so
it's going to show the kind of [ __ ] that
i tend to watch yeah yeah yeah yeah but
when
she picks it shows random [ __ ] that
would never pop up my [ __ ] do you know
what i mean
the algorithm's different different and
some of the stuff she picks
i would never pick but sometimes they
bang
there's a movie called bird i can't
describe it
but i've heard of it i think it's i
would never watch it yeah yeah
ever it would not even show up on my
algorithm yeah but i was like this is
actually a dope movie
um i can't remember what it's about but
watch it if you're interested
but there's a show have you ever called
her have you ever heard of a show
called dating around it's a date show on
netflix i've heard of it i've never
watched it
bro is it live bro it's the livestation
show i've ever seen obviously she picks
it
she swears she picked the show i mean
i'mma give you the premise the show is
amazing talk to me
i'm all literally all is the show is
amazing tell me
okay my skin's itching tell me
the show is amazing so it's a
it's a blind date show so she um
obviously you for example you're going
on blind so you have five identical
blind dates
at the same spot and you do the same
routine so you go for
drinks at the bar you go for food you
do an afterthing and then you you go
home that's that's the routine of the
day
yeah what do you do with you would do it
for example you'll do it with five
different goals
yeah same date same thing but the way
it's edited they will show different
parts of different people
during that during the one episode yeah
yeah so it's one episode per
five dates yeah so the first
the first thing is like you meet them
but you get to know each other
you have you have the drinks then you
have the food then you have to take
but certain man so for you for example
certain girls wouldn't make it to the to
the home stage like sharing a taxi home
stage because
you've pied some off around okay and
when you start at the beginning they
show the five girls
yeah for example yeah and they'd be like
you you kind of had to in your head you
want to pick who you think you would
pick
yeah i mean straight off the bat yeah
yeah yeah but the more and more you get
into it the more some people surprise
you
and what they say and how they what kind
of chemistry they have and blah blah
blah
so the first brother was he i think he
was like
filipino vietnamese kind of thing but he
was
he wasn't cocky but his confidence was a
one like the five girls he picked he
could have picked any of them
his confidence was a gang one asian
brothers have it going on it was just
it was just mad he and the thing is with
with this dating show
obviously all the five dates happen in
one day for example it's not one day but
it happens
at that same period this year yeah but
then the last
scene at the end of the episode is who
they pick
for the second date which is a
completely different day and it's during
the day
so they've got change of outfit blah
blah blah but it takes you about 10
seconds to see who they pick because
they just walk up yeah yeah on the
street yeah you're like oh gang it was
this person was that person yeah yeah so
you get to see who they pick at the end
yeah yeah and you never get to see what
happens after that
which is but i only ever found out after
this after the episode was one was done
because obviously second episode is
completely different people yeah yeah
so episode one was the um asian brother
and it was confident as [ __ ] the second
episode bro
there was a guy i was a guy and
obviously five girls yeah but the there
was
i don't want to say he has something
wrong with him but you could just
no it's pete because that's that was my
immediate yeah yeah because he
he's so i think the best way to describe
it he's just energetic
he every because they they give you like
a back
background of him who he is like he's
bredren's talk about him during like the
opening scene oh he's such a nice guy i
wish you that
but you know you don't hear him speak
but it's only when he meets the first
yeah that he speaks
and he's like ah like he's so
he he must have like adhd or something i
don't i don't want to say he has that
but
yeah do you know what i mean is he kind
of like spectrum a little bit something
like that but he's uh
the thing is as soon as i've heard him
speak the first second i judged him off
the bat yeah and i was like
these are gonna be terrible oh god all
five dates are gonna be
terrible yeah bro yeah yeah he's a white
guy
and he won the heart of everyone
he won my heart family he's such he's
the epitome of a nice
human being you know what i mean he went
on a date with
one of the one of the girls was a black
girl and i was thinking this is just not
going to bang
because one he's not even necessary
because he's white just because the kind
of person he was yeah yeah yeah
and she had kids the black girl had two
kids already yeah
but that came up later on in the day and
i was just like
this this is not gonna bang i just
really know it's not gonna be bad
but the chemistry they had bro they were
staring at each other at the restaurant
and then he was like i'm going to be
polite because he's a such a polite
ghost like i really want to kiss you can
i
can i kiss you and she's like oh on the
cheek and it was it was just so nice bro
but there was one guy that was one yet
he really really really liked
and they shared a taxi home yeah yeah
yeah yeah they dropped her off first
before they dropped him off
and he was like i really want to do this
again can we exchange numbers rare
tatter
and then he was like ah i just see you
more as a friend kind of thing blah blah
blah and he was like oh
okay cool and then she got out the taxi
a man put his hand on the ting and a
tear ran down his face fam
i do you know the thing i obviously i
felt
bad i felt like it was me but what made
it worse was
i remember this was a date yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like these men are
recording this
live yeah if i'm the priest i'm stopping
the whole
thing you can't break my man's heart
like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah gigs no no
i would break up i'll cut the whole
thing and say let's do that again
because you have to take my man's number
it broke me bro he's the nicest man in
the world
he's the nicest guy i love nice guys oh
it broke he was like and a tear
a tear ran down his face
it broke me they'll cut it it broke me
i want to take every [ __ ] ah i want
to take every nice guy
and just i don't even know
like pay for him to [ __ ] the the
penguins
ever i remember when i was when i was
younger
ah i had an impasse in my life where i'd
grown into my teeth and i was looking
all right
you love talking about it to my teeth
you don't understand how ugly i was when
i
when my teeth fell out and i was [ __ ]
hideous
and i couldn't live for myself but
anyway i've grown into my teeth and i
was looking okay at this point
i've been boxing for a couple years so
your boy was a bit lean as well
your boy was a bit lean and a bit nippy
so quick and obviously
at the age i was like 15 16. yeah so no
one was wham
so it didn't matter if you were if you
had a six pack
you would win you're winning
so this is the time uh it's like
people's sweet 16 birthday parties and
things like that so we're just
just getting into the drinking scene now
okay
and uh i had my my friend his name was
gary right
his name was gary gary is the nicest
[ __ ] guy you've ever met and he was
like a short
at the time i don't i haven't spoke to
him in years i don't know what he's like
now but at the time he was just like a
short
wimpy little kid who just wanted
[ __ ] and he went to love he wanted to
have a [ __ ] girlfriend like
he'd never had a girlfriend and he
really wanted a girlfriend but no one
wanted to go out with him
no one and like i remember we were on a
night out
at this like party or whatever and he
was like
i really want to dance with someone like
i i just want to dance with a girl in it
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm going to
get you a dance tonight
like i'm not this is the last thing i do
is it's the last thing i do
i'm going to get you a dance tonight and
knowing me in my head i'm
overconfident i'm probably gonna get you
some [ __ ] yeah
these are i probably haven't had sex yet
but i'm gonna get gary some [ __ ]
[ __ ] today yeah yeah yeah cause like
he's too nice
and then bro we were just going through
going through going through like go
after go off the go and i'm like
and i was like in my head i'm like [ __ ]
like no one's into this guy
yeah and then he turned to me and he was
like bro it
is what it is like sometimes like you
just have to take your light in life and
i was like what do you mean
like you're amazing brother and he's
like bro i'm not you like look at you
like
you're like the coolest black guy ever
and i was just like
safe in my head i was doing backflips
but as i wrote on my cool guy routine i
was like
it was like bro i'm not like you it is
like you're a cool black guy like i'm
just like nothing
and i was like [ __ ] that i was getting
so
angry at all i was getting so angry at
everyone like [ __ ] that if you actually
get to know my man
if you love know him you'll love him but
the big thing is as well all the yats
that did know him loved him but just not
like that
they just didn't want to [ __ ] him
everyone liked him but no one wanted to
[ __ ] him
and i was like i need i need to get you
late tonight or i need to give you a
dance or something cuz
and then i went up to one girl i
remember it was
both the sexiest and coolest but
in hindsight the actually most
depressing thing that's ever happened
is that i went to one ting and she was a
[ __ ] spice
she was actually a [ __ ] spice and she
was like the ninth ting that we'd spoken
to
and at this point i i'd seen her from
early but i was like i'm not even gonna
ask
her yeah she's she's a buffalo yeah know
what i mean so no
she's never gonna go for gary and then
i went up to her i'd had a few drinks at
this point so i was feeling confident
loose
loose i had a silver tongue i was
feeling loose
i wasn't rolled up to her i was like hey
how are you doing everything and it's
it's funny because obviously i've told
you a million times i can't talk to
girls yeah
but it just turns out i can't talk to
girls on my own behalf when i'm doing it
for someone else
i can chat okay so my confidence was up
because it's not false not for you
in my head i'm like i've got nothing to
lose yeah if she prizes me she's not
paying me
she's buying gas yeah i guess so i'm
like all right cool
and she's like i was like oh hey what's
up and she was like hey what's going on
and i was just basically explaining the
situation just like obviously
sorry where were you are you in a subs
or like a house thing uh shops
okay so it was like it was like a thing
where someone had rented it out oh okay
there's something for this party
there's bear people there okay um and it
was like one of them ones is where
people that age you know when people are
so desperate to drink when they're 16
that if you hear there's a party through
the grapevine you're going you're dead
you're going everyone is there
hundreds of people were there yeah yeah
yeah didn't know none of them so i
rolled up to and i was like hey what's
up my name is james etc talking talking
talking she was like okay what's up and
i was like cool so long story short
my guy is the is is the is the buffest
nicest guy and she was like who and i
was like him she was like
and i was like trust me cuz like he's
the [ __ ] nicest guy and you'd be
[ __ ] lucky
to secure a wine from my man and i said
he can dance
like he can dance babe could he though
no okay he's never danced with anyone
but i was selling him hi yeah and then i
said like obviously
you'd be doing me a big favor if you
could just spend some time with my boy
gary
get to know him a little bit and have a
dance with my son he would make his
night like he would make his night and
she was like
um i'll be real with you i would love to
she said to me i would love to dance
with you but i'm not dancing with him
and in my head i was like swear
down your butt and
i've never been in such a fork in the
road while thinking i want a snake my
friend
i want to snake my friend because he's
waiting in the wings for me to call him
through
and i want to take her hand and [ __ ] off
you want to do it so
if you want to patent it so well that if
three people cross your path so he can
no longer see you you've dragged them
you've dead you're
gone dipped gone like you're in movies
when you see something
that's good and they just fade into the
mist
that's what i wanted to happen um i
wanted us to disappear to the
table you love a disabled toilet thing
it's so funny little girl i would never
forget the girl in the register where he
said that's a disabled twilight
i was laughing bro when you said that
fam
uh disabled toilet things are spicy
spicy because they're just like disabled
what are the moments yeah um anyway
she i was like [ __ ] my dick
and i was just like [ __ ] all right cool
well i i remember
it was i was proud of myself at the same
time i really wasn't i was just like you
know what
dance with my boy mm-hmm and i will
spend the rest of the night with you
guys with my boy and i'll buy you drinks
and we'll do all sorts and she was like
all right gang
so she danced with him long story short
i think
she was with her girls i was my boys i
think we spoke like one more time and
nothing really came with it so it was
all luck
but he secured his wine he was gassed
and it was just like
in hindsight it's such a sad situation
but at the time i was like
this is the nicest [ __ ] guy and i
feel like i just want to take care of
him forever and make sure he literally
gets
everything that life ever deserves but
that's just not how a man should live i
know do you know what i mean yeah
and like i was just like oh [ __ ] man i
don't know why that sticks on here but
when you said about the night i was just
like
gary just the nicest i love nice guys
and i hate when they get a [ __ ] hand
yeah i hate when they get a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hand because it's like bro you deserve
better
there's um would you remember when i was
telling you meant to watch terra's house
yes yes the japanese thing
so um for anyone
who's never heard of it terrace house is
on netflix you have to watch it
you have to watch exactly what you just
said it's kind of like a dating show
kind of where it's like basically three
girls three guys move into a house
together
and they just live there they still have
to work their normal lives so they still
have to go to work every day they have
to do everything but they just live in
the house together
and the idea is once they find love they
move out
okay so or if they've decided they can't
find love in their house they move up
so there's one guy in there called ruka
and he was the youngest one in there he
was
20 i think he was 20. everyone else is
like 25 26 up to about 29.
um and he like
he didn't really have like a part-time
job and you know how these japanese man
obviously you watch anime stuff these
japanese men they're all about honor and
pride
and like systematically thought like you
need to be going places
like you need like they're impressed by
not necessarily money
but drive like aspirations they're
impressed by like if you've got your
life in order that's what the ass won
yeah and he just didn't have his life in
order yeah but
that's fine for him but but as long as
if if everyone else in there was 20
they wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah but
because they're all older they're
looking down on him like mentality get
your [ __ ] together kind of thing
so he couldn't cook he couldn't he could
clean but he couldn't cook he couldn't
clean he slept in
he only had a part-time job and they
used to ask him like what do you want to
do like what do you want to do
and he said i want to be a superhero but
he actually meant it and they thought
like he was talking like
a marvel like an actor or like a stunt
man or stuff like that and they're all
trying to help mother oh why don't you
do this why do you do that and
but they take it so seriously like oh if
you want to be an actor like you need to
start learning english you need to do
these things and he was just like
no i don't actu i don't want to be an
actor like i
genuinely want to be a superhero and
obviously
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but you just
you kind of feel for him because he's
the nicest guy and
of all the criticism that they oh they
gave him [ __ ] yeah and all the criticism
they ever gave him he never
ever got angry never ever got angry and
there was one thing that moved in and he
was gassed off of her yeah
gassed off of her if you had gassed off
of her and he was asking how do you
write your name like what symbols do you
use for yeah
so she told him and he wrote it out and
he was like oh
like if you look here i think you could
find his name in with
within her name with the symbol so he
was like oh that's cool and she was like
oh that's cool
and then that night he wrote that like a
hundred times in this notebook
so they all the yes the next day when
he's in bed the ass came downstairs and
they saw the notebook sit in there and
it just had bear
and they were laughing at him laughing
at ruka
like that's there was a that's cute but
it's creepy and all this stuff and they
were just having a giggle
man had no idea but the thing with
terrace house is
while they're in because they're in
there for months so while they're in
here
the episodes are airing week by week so
you can see the episodes
you can go and watch your own episodes
oh that episode came on a couple weeks
later
and they're in there and he's actually
seeing that like
oh i'm the joke of the house like i'm
the joke of the house and he's watching
it and he's just watching
like how they're just bagging him out
about this notebook and all this stuff
and he's sitting there like just like
he wants to cry like he's sitting there
he wants to cry and i'm watching there
thinking oh he's gonna come out all guns
blazing
he's gonna come out like [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you man
and bro he comes out he tells a couple
of his boys i'm gonna be leaving the
house and stuff like that and then he
has this like he cooks his
this dinner so basically i'm getting
at the beginning of the show he can't
cook and everyone's cussing them out
because he can't get me for [ __ ] yeah so
he says oh i want to make
um he wants to make people like dinner
one time
and he makes this like carbonara thing
with broccoli in it it's disgusting
what he makes was [ __ ] disgusting it
was like basically that scrambled egg
with spaghetti and like unseasoned
broccoli
it was dirt and broccoli pasta okay and
then there's an italian guy in there he
was gang and he
how i was with gary he is with ruka okay
and he did not like the fact that he
ruka was just the butt of the joke
so like if ruka wanted to draw something
the guy who moved in the italian guy
he's a a manga artist who moved from
italy to japan to
to be professional uh and then ruka was
like doing dumb sketches one time and
all the girls were like bagging rooker
out look at this [ __ ] drawing and
they were like nah man it's actually
kind of abstract if you look at this and
there's a lot of artists like do this
and there's actually like da vinci would
do a lot of stuff like this
and you're like this guy's riding for
ruka so when he did the broccoli pasta
thing he was oh actually in italy
if you find out the real carbonara was
actually just made out of scraps so rook
is actually just
hitting the roots of the carbonara and
stuff like he was always riding for ruka
he hated
he hated when everyone would [ __ ] on him
i like that so they would bag him out
for not
knowing english they bag him out for not
being able to cook their bag about for
not having his life together and all
this stuff so
the days are moving out i'm waiting for
him the day before he moved out he'd
just seen the the the video of everyone
cussing him out all the time
the notebook and i'm waiting for him to
go guns blazing on these [ __ ]
like you know what
since the day i got here all you've done
is put me down no one wants to go on
dates with me no one's taking me
seriously all you want to do is cuss me
out for my dreams and my drawings and my
love letters and
all this [ __ ] like i'm tired of it and
i'm leaving that's what i thought was
gonna happen
yeah and the whole time he's the nicest
guy you've never seen him angry family
comes out on his last day he invites
everyone to dinner
he made a meal he went to see a
professional chef
who taught him how to make an actual
broccoli pasta dish so he
cooked pasta from scratch with the flour
and everything put a pasta from scratch
with broccoli in it in like a carbonara
fashion he actually made it
like a quality dish with the broccoli
pasta because for
the the broccoli pasta was the butter
the joke for the entire show
ruka's broccoli pasta and how disgusting
it was and he actually went to see a
professional of how to make
actual banging broccoli pasta and he
made it for everyone
and then he read out he wrote a letter
in english
because he was taking secret english
lessons and then
he just read out a whole a whole thing
in english
and his english was so infuriatingly
broken
but it was heart-wrenching and he was
basically like
i just want to thank you guys for all
the support
and all these times that when they're
cussing them out
he's seeing it as i actually just need
to do better
i just need to do better and fam i
wanted to cry
my [ __ ] eyes out that no one gave
this man love for the entire show
and in the end all he wants to do is say
thank you
it's the best show you can watch it's
the best [ __ ] show you can watch
the ruka sagar ah you just wanna
you wanna adopt him yeah you wanna adopt
him and you're just like
he's so nice he's so nice why is he so
[ __ ] nice like why did nice guys
finish last all the time because
girls want [ __ ] they do girls want
pricks because
they don't want nice guys at all they
think they want nice guys
but they don't they really don't man
from the street
it's like what you said to me yesterday
about um
you don't want the guy the best sex of
your life ting say that
so yeah yeah what i was saying if you
had yesterday train wreck the film train
wreck
and there's a scene in there where this
girl's in a relationship and she's
trying to she's trying to look for
excuses to get out of the relationship
basically and she's basically the guy
that she's [ __ ]
the sex is great but it's not the best
set she's ever had and she's like surely
the guy i end up with she'll be the best
sex you've ever had
and she's talking to her sister and her
sister's like big one you don't want the
best sex you've ever had
because the guy that gave you the best
you've ever had is in prison like he's
in jail
that's that kind of sex that's what
women want that's rough
sex that's abuse sex bro that's
borderline abuse sex
i love that sex it's fantastic the thing
is i've been on both sides of the
spectrum
you know what's weird about it is that
you've been on both sides of the
spectrum is because like
guys also don't want that
i'm probably ruining the game for
everyone now yeah but
women and men both want the same thing
when they don't really realize it
because women don't want their
husband to be the best dick they've ever
had because the best thing they've ever
had
was a guy that they actually probably
don't like as a person they're just
[ __ ] like
he was just [ __ ] meat to them muscle
and meat and disgraceful pipe
they just want a guy to run through and
[ __ ] the living [ __ ] out of him
and leave him for dead yeah basically
that's what a lot of women want
that's the best sex they've had but they
don't want that every [ __ ] day like i
said it's like
it's like snorting coke ever you don't
want it every day you don't want that
for
breakfast lunch and dinner in moderation
you want that in moderation like you
want that once in a while to just get
wrecked and just have the time of your
life you can't
live like that but that doesn't mean you
don't ever want to have fun again
exactly
just because you don't want to do
ecstasy every day doesn't mean you don't
enjoy fun just like just because you
don't want a guy to run through and
wreck your walls down
doesn't mean you don't ever want to have
sex again like so they don't want their
husband to do that to them
but they want the best sex of their life
is not going to come from their husband
yeah
just like guys like sometimes they'll
they
well a lot of the time they want to go
and they just want to [ __ ]
wreck a ago yeah wreck like
disgraceful head eating pum eating us
eating ass from the front and the sides
like anal
butt plugs and whips leashes the whole
nine yards that's what they want yeah
but
i don't want to do that to my wife every
day no
i can't i can't live like that but that
doesn't mean i don't want sex ever again
sometimes i just want to do missionary
and lips
sometimes missionary and lips bro i ride
for a missionary lips sometimes
well like that love sex sometimes it's
trouble
everything slow missionary sex sometimes
it's so
underrated yes i do love to run trains
on her sometimes
but missionary love sex
is a different game that's that's how
you know we're older
because some some of our viewers or
listeners might think
nah shut up
you man are chatting i want hoes for the
rest of my life i want
something off every day that's what some
of these young things are they haven't
experienced
they have not experienced love
missionary sex they have not experienced
it
fam when you man are kissing
when you men are kissing
and it's just slow and your stroke is
right game is just
everything and you just not at the same
time
and it's just friction and sweat oh
friction
sweat and just and not even guilt just
filth i don't know it's everything fam
it's just fluids
there's just flutes everybody's just not
even it's not even slimy it's just
[ __ ] amazing sexy you don't know you
don't know if you've been there for five
minutes or an hour yeah like you don't
know what's going
on yeah yeah yeah and you're just
it's amazing sometimes those ones are
fan they're [ __ ] fantastic they're
the best they are the best they actually
are the best they're the best it's weird
because obviously i love
rough [ __ ] yeah but those ones those
ones are the [ __ ] best
and you can't just have that with any
stranger i can't it has to be
have to be someone that you have good
feelings
it's crazy it's a double-edged sword
it's a double-edged sword
because you want both you do want both
but yeah you can't you can't be
yeah you can't be just having filth
every day you can't live life like that
there's not a way to live your life but
um i don't even know what the topic of
the discussion is
nice guys yeah so nice guys nice guys
want to do that missionary [ __ ] every
day
every day and it's like it's cause they
don't know girls they're never gonna
want that yeah
and they finished last oh it's such a
shame it is a shame man because nice
guys are the best bet i'm gonna watch
the terrorists i know you've told me to
watch it time ago but i'm actually watch
it
episode three of the dating show just go
dating around
it's called dating around it's in
america it's based in america yeah i'm a
priet man
and i'm gonna watch it episode three is
a woman
so i'm thinking okay this is gonna be
sick i wanna see what the guys think but
then
it flips it because obviously i told you
they show the people that they're gonna
date at the beginning
yeah he's bisexual so it shows guys and
girls and i'm thinking
oh i wonder who she's gonna [ __ ] pick
and there's this bread on there on this
same episode this is there's this guy
he's very intriguing it went from
pure interest to pure crazy so quick
elab so he said satin along the lines of
no she asked him um
why do you date bisexuals he said
he only dates bisexuals and i was first
of all thinking
what let's just take them a bit i was
thinking this is loud as [ __ ] trust me
i was thinking what that's i've never
heard anyone say that and she's like
explain yourself
explain yourself yeah and he said
the way i love women i have to be with a
woman that equally loves women the same
way
i do to understand me and i thought
that is the deepest thing i have ever
heard in my entire life
wow you see it now wow in my entire life
twist plot twist plot that was
interesting yes
i'll be crazy i'll be hooked if i was
hurt i'll be hooked
but it flipped to crazy because he's
he's polygamous
so he [ __ ] other yachts so he wants to
be have a one he wants to have a bottom
[ __ ] and [ __ ] over yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then in the they shared
at this point they had shared a taxi
ride home because she was interested
but then she asked him is she allowed to
[ __ ] other guys
and he said flat up no flat out no you
can't play like that no and she was like
do you not think that's sexist
no do you not think that's like um
not discriminative a bit um that's what
i'm looking for
what's the word when you do something
but you don't let no someone else do it
hypocritical
do you not think it's hypocritical no
wow
blunt as [ __ ] blunt as [ __ ] and he was
like and he was like
oh i'm sure i'll see you again this is
when they dropped him off obviously oh
she's the main guy yeah yeah yeah
i'm sure i'll see you again i should
yeah i'm sure you
never saw she i'm not gonna tell you
episode unique
i want you to go for every episode i'll
jump on
episode four was another yeah it's the
buffest thing you will ever
see game sold sold i don't think you
understand she's
literally the pennies thing bro the
tangiest thing
i need to see like this show is great
man i need to take it around
this show is great i'm jumping on anyone
that's not watched it before or has
watched it
uh comment or whatever or if you not
watch watching please watch it i'll jump
on our job i'll just watch it
so amazing oh amazing i'll jump on it
but yeah uh i will watch terrorists as
well because that when you told me i
wrote you thing and said
i want to thank you very much it was
crushing it's gonna remind you of
episode
two when i told you about that guy that
cried in the whip all right gang all
right it's the most heart-wrenching
thing i've ever seen bro
[ __ ] all right most heart-wrenching
thing i've ever seen i'm down i'm no no
no no no no no no no no no no no [ __ ]
all right let's do it the [ __ ] let's
i think we've got one i'm pretty sure i
said
one donny sent us one you'd i think he
did
and then i just said i have m's i think
yeah i didn't even look into it
let's have a look see hang on
oh jesus oh while he's look trying to
find one guys
subscribe to our sng clips as well man
it's a little shortened version of what
we do on the main page
if you're not into sitting there or
watching 45 to an hour a minute long
episodes we've got short bursts
10 to 20 minutes of clips from the main
episodes
so if you fancy that subscribe button
going it's funny [ __ ] right
okay cool so one donny asking if he's
the [ __ ]
yeah so i'm in high school
right okay yeah in high school i broke
into my
best friend's house to lose my virginity
while her and her parents went home
so backstory i went to a house party
that got busted
and my parents would murder me to know i
was drinking in high school
so i called my friend's mum and she let
me stay
at their home and told me if anything
urgent comes up i'm free to break in the
house
and i don't like that if you use the
word i'm free to break in the house
because i'm like are you breaking in or
not i got okay well anyway free to come
in the yard
and we can talk about it later yeah so i
had this chick i was trying to get with
me
pulled up to my house and my parents
were home so waited for my friend to
leave for work
broke in her house and had sex on her
bed i've still yet to tell my best
friend
the question is am i the ass for that do
you know why i'm annoyed
because go on obviously you said it
my man sent that to us and i've saw you
responsible we're going to talk about on
the show
but i had already read the message so i
already had a preconceived answer in my
head so
okay this isn't fresh to me yeah yeah
i'm also annoyed
that you [ __ ] her in the brethren's
bed yes that would
infur if i found that out yes that would
infuriate yes
yes infuriate me yes yes because you've
already we've already given you
the leeway to come to the yard if push
comes to shark yeah
yeah you've literally shoved and [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my bed
do you know what i mean you i gave you
an inch i gave you you took the whole
you took seven nine miles you know what
i mean yeah yeah
it's a it's a violation more than
anything like 100 i would say he's asked
you could have [ __ ] anywhere yeah
sorry bro that's the thing if
if someone gives me free reign of their
house to [ __ ] a girl
i'm not going in their bed if i can
avoid it i don't need to go in their bed
you know what i mean like we can [ __ ]
anywhere anywhere
floor sofa stairs for [ __ ] say kitchen
counter
anywhere i don't need to take it into
your bed and then to this day the man
said
i haven't told her so he already knows
he's the [ __ ] because he hasn't even
told her
but yeah don't and it's not even your
boy's bed it's a girl's bed
so that's different as well a girl
doesn't want to know you [ __ ] another
girl in her bed
come on bruv that's not because it's
there's broco to certain things
like one of my boys can [ __ ] in my bed
and i'm not gonna be happy about it
but first of all just tell me the truth
sort out the sheets and we'll move like
it's minor it's a big deal of things
it's minor yeah in the grand scheme yeah
yeah yeah but as long as you're open
about it yeah for a girl though yeah
this is violation like imagine me taking
a girl into bella's bed and [ __ ] her
i'm not telling bella about it ryan
shiblo what the [ __ ] are you doing fam
violation what are you doing riley yeah
it's a mistake but uh yeah sorry bro
you're the [ __ ] like
yeah you are you are you are you like
you you had the opportunity
um they gave you to have your cake and
eat it too man you had a free yard
they let you use it you bought a thing
back there you could have done what's
right and just still bust your nut and
everything's blessed but you had to take
it one step further you had to take it
to the bedroom's bed
and not even a spare room or nothing
guys bedrooms bed and [ __ ] on there
it's because that was planned like he
wanted to [ __ ] have regency yeah yeah
of course that's a pissed if he turned
him on a little bit a little bit you
probably turned him on
you might fancy the girl maybe maybe
maybe he fancies the friend maybe she's
not having it if i can't get her
i'm gonna do all sorts of yeah i'm gonna
pretend i am [ __ ] her
that's probably what he did that's pr i
see it all and i see it clearer now yeah
he's pretended the yacht is the bridge
yeah yeah the quote unquote
yeah like i'm gonna call you casey just
so you know what you mean just sharp i'm
gonna call you casey for a bit
for a bit she's just like all right cool
all right cool whatever man that's fine
um but cool man all right
bless guys let's rap